it wasn't my choice really to leave to
Syria I was forced to do it
getting Soria I had a comfortable life
in my own home but when I was forced to
live I had to start from the scratch
when I first got here I would think
about going back every day I miss my
little house and was my friends my world
community I live I miss our little
coffee which we were hanging out and
having our coffee there when I first got
here I would not buy anything like any
stuff you know for the house because I
would think what would really you know
fit in my bag if I want to go back I
came here by myself on my daughter and
we are here alone I'm watching her
growing up in a safer place learning a
new language she's always thinking about
Syria I feel that this could all be a
waste and I fear that I have to live the
moment when Assad is back in power and
I'm right here and I have to wake up
every day in the morning and look at
myself in the mirror and tell myself
that was it the right thing to do my
biggest fear that I will not see my
country again I will not see my home
again
I miss it like hellovenus I miss being
there being able you know to live in my
place with my neighbors to walk down the
lastest streets feeling you know
smelling just the Jasmine around
greeting people in the morning standing
in the mornings line to get some bread
back you know the fresh bread back home
getting the best homeless ever in the
Middle East all of that it just
I miss all of that and museu even know
the London a label me
Poseidon SP yeah hi hi article I feel
like I betrayed my my friends and the
people and left behind its I fell for
the world it's not Syrian film it's the
word fear
they felt that Syrian still fighting for
their freedom and dignity and they will
take it at the rockin SP anna german ich
mich are most often in osaka wat anima
hardly beside energy they decide next
week